prime minister Dominic Rob is with us
did you know it was his birthday but
he's looking pretty good on it I think
that might have been a little while ago
but there we go 10
times what are you up to
well look we know that housing uh the
illegal migrants that arrive here in
hotels six million pounds a day it's a
huge cost of course it just encourages
the business model of the criminal gangs
to send more and more on this pair of
this journey so we've got to deal with
it I think it's very frustrating for
your viewers and for the public we're
going to look at the whole range of
options uh cheaper lower cost
accommodations we'll look at we'll look
at barges it's been done elsewhere in
Europe it's been done in Scotland we'll
look at ex-military barracks and the
immigration minister is going to set out
the detail in front of the house it
comes to us so he'll tell us that there
are barges later on today well he's
going to tell you the whole range of
options and what we're doing but
nothing's off the table we must end if
you like this perverse incentive through
the hotels and more generally with the
hospitality the in a broader sense this
country gives encouraging the wrong
people which is the criminal gangs and
legal migrants to make this very
dangerous Journey it's not right why do
you think barges would be a deterrent
well I think the hotels are the
incentive and we've got to get off the
uh six million pound a day tax bill for
these hotels uh barges would be one
possible option along with ex-military
Barracks
six million pounds a day uh being housed
in hotels it can't be right it's not
right as a matter of policy it's not
writer as a matter of the cost so we'll
look at all the other options I mean
barges are one aspect of it the papers
are picked up on it and that's fine and
nothing is off the table but the clear
message is we're going to tackle uh what
is effectively an abuse of the system
how can it be table
um why is it even on the table when
you've been told previously as a
government that it would be illegal I
don't think it would be illegal it
depends on the circumstances the
conditions it's been done elsewhere in
European countries uh I think it's been
found in Scotland so we'll get that
policy right but what we're clear on is
the basic idea that you can get on an
illegal boat run by some gangster uh on
a transnational basis get into this
country and then be housed in a hotel at
the total cost of six million pounds a
day that is going to end this Tuesday
feels absolutely not so local MPS
including the foreign secretary how did
that conversation go look the planning
applications are notoriously uh complex
and they'll be carried out at a local
level of course the government will work
with the local authorities uh spoken to
the foreign
okay so during the cabinet meeting
yesterday this wasn't brought up James
cleverly said absolutely not in my
backyard well as you know okay I don't
divulge the internal discussions in
cabinet I was sat right next to James
and I know he's fully supports his
policy he doesn't he doesn't he
literally does not want it to happen in
his backyard you can speak to James
about his views I sat next to him and I
know the whole cabinet is supportive of
ending this practice of a perverse
incentive which encourages the gangsters
again and that I nearly forgot that is
coming yeah that is coming from the
foreign aid budget so that money would
be spent anyway you're actually using a
third of the foreign aid budget when you
shouldn't actually be doing that well
this is you've just strengthened the
case for ending this perverse practice
that money should be going on helping
the most vulnerable whether it's from
humanitarian disasters or poverty
alleviation it shouldn't go on expensive
hotels uh to house illegal might be
doing that absolutely so we need to find
the alternative uh your right needs to
be done the humane way and that's what
the immigration this is going to be
setting out to Parliament today okay we
were hearing from Davey who was sat
there a short while ago and he said what
you need to do is employ more people to
process these people we're dealing with
that I mean it's classically Dem
flip-flopping can't really grapple with
any serious issue reality is they block
all of our attempts to deal with illegal
migration and the point I would make is
that it's not a Humane or humanitarian
thing to do because you're encouraging
the model that gets more people making
this perilous dangerous miserable
journey and puts lives at risk
I know but how many people have you
actually employed in addition to the
ones that are already working at the
home office to start processing oh
there's a massive increase in in
caseworkers I don't know the numbers but
I can tell you for example on the
nationality and borders act that we put
in place and everyone said well what's
it going to deliver 160 uh have been
convicted the combined sentences are
over a hundred years so that was one
measure we're taking we've got the
illegal migration Bill coming through
that pass with a whacking great majority
through the House of Commons at second
reading blocked by labor of course
opposed by labor we're going to see it
through anyway and the next step is what
the immigration minister is going to say
today about ending this abuse of hotels
which just encourages these dangerous
Journeys yeah but the Home Secretary sat
here and said that she would start to
increase numbers I'm asking you since I
don't know six weeks ago when she was
sat there how many more people have you
employed well I don't know in terms of
the caseworkers but I can tell you is
that we're hiring uh something like 150
more judges so when those cases get to
the immigration Asylum chamber we've got
great account to see it through and I
know because I've talked with the Home
Secretary that they're making sure
they've got the caseworkers and we're
doing it in one joined up way so we can
get through those decisions more quickly
more decisively and end this practice in
a fair Humane but but very clear way
yeah I mean I'm just looking at my notes
the government warned by their lawyers
your actual own actual lawyers that
putting migrants on ships would be
illegal and that was back in October
well look that wouldn't be true can't
Blanchard that's not changed since
October no no but it all depends on the
circumstance of the case we'll make sure
we get the policy right we legally
scrutinize these things you'd expect me
to do that as Justice secretary and I'm
confident uh we'll get this right but
the real uh breach of Human Rights and
uh the real cause of human misery is the
practice of uh vast numbers coming
across in small boats and we got to
crush that business model that the
gangsters rely on and part of that is
making sure that they don't realize and
they know that there's not a plush hotel
at taxpayers expense at the end of that
illegal Journey you've been into any of
these hotels I won't describe them as
plush well uh I I think actually for
most people
um being
housed in a hotel with all of the
amenities that that has is not something
that is appropriate for people coming
here literally
um talk to me about the victim's uh Bill
particularly I want to know about Levi
bellfield and whether it be able to get
married before the bill comes into play
so look there's uh two big things that
we're doing one putting victims at the
center of all of the criminal justice
system does we're putting the victim's
code into law so that they got a
statutory duties to make sure that
victims get the information the port
Support Services the right to have a
review of their case we're backing that
up with teeth at the local level and in
terms of the national inspectors on
parole reform I'm making sure that we've
got greater control and ministerial
check or release of the most dangerous
criminals like murderers rapists
terrorists and child killers and I think
it is also right in cases which attract
a whole life order in the case like Levi
Belfield or it's not about one
individual that if they're in prison for
such serious offenses in this case we're
talking about a serial killer that they
don't have the ability to marry I think
that's right as a matter of protection
of vulnerable women who could be at
serious risk but it's also right I think
for confidence in the justices yeah but
is he going to be able to get married or
not look I don't talk about individual
cases that will go through the process
in the normal way but I think the public
would expect us to have the control over
these kind of systems and procedures and
as I said it's been great if you did
that wouldn't it well I agree with you
that's why I'm introducing these changes
okay talk to me are you doing pmqs today
I am okay that's amazing are you looking
forward to it always okay talk to me
about the fact that this investigation
this Adam trolley investigation 126 days
since he first started looking into
bullying
um allegations uh against you and what
sort of impact is it having on you
I'm a professional uh I called for the
investigation so there's no point me
complaining about it I want to make sure
I address it as assiduously as I can I
can't comment further it's an
independent investigation but I'm asking
what impact it's having I look I'm a
professional look I
um I want to respect uh I've always said
I behave with professional integrity and
part of that is respecting and inquiry
not least because I called for it and it
will conclude when it concludes that's
not within my control my question my
questions how is it impacting on you
look anyone accused of things that you
feel very passionately and heart and
soul are wrong you will feel uh agreed
but unprofessional
um uh I'm very focused on the job I do
I've got a great set of civil servants
working with me you can see that we are
focused on the job because we're
bringing forward the victims in prisoner
bill today we've responded to the Wade
review on homicide I'm standing in for
the PM on pmqs and I'm very focused on
my job
um I had Rhys Smog on the program the
other day and he said he was talking
about this and he said you need to worry
about snowflakes
what's your question for me do you need
to worry about snowflakes look I think
we've got fantastic civil servants I've
got a long experience working various
different departments uh overwhelmingly
the job they do is is exceptionally good
and the relationship with ministers is
very good I do think that having
Professional Standards uh having high
standards being demanding being rigorous
is is exactly what's required when it
comes to standing up for victims when it
comes to signing up for public
protection which is what this
legislation we're doing is going to do
and look uh you need to be direct you
need to be forthright that's not
bullying and I think it can be done in a
way which is respectful and the critical
thing here of course people who think
back to Yes Minister and this sort of uh
binary adversarial relationship actually
and I can say this as a former foreign
office lawyer I was there for six years
what we do best is get the best out the
sum of our parts the civil servants as
ministers civil servants give candid
advice ministers give the challenge but
frankly the direction and the
assertiveness that's required that's how
you things done that's what we're
sharing with our victims in prisoner
bill today okay I know you've got lots
to do given that you've got prime
minister's questions so I better let you
go it's good to talk to you as always
thank you very much indeed Deputy Prime
Minister thank you and coming up in the